hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and I am Cody Meltzer and this is
cameras never seen and Cody's also never
seen it as well I guess today we are
going to watch Green Lantern oh man I
wish I had one of those like party like
the button I could do it real slowly you
are a very big fan of Green Lantern but
we're both very big at DC Marvel fans
yeah and have purposefully ignored no I
was a big feeling of family I was
younger but Alan Scott is what got me
into the Green Lantern's and Alan Scott
is where it remains
I have contradictory opinions to like
the masses so this is a chance all like
this you know because I don't like
actual Hal Jordan so maybe I'll like
this Hal Jordan knows
yeah but I'm doubtful will you snap with
me yeah of course on three one two three
[Music]
[Laughter]
most predictable
most bland basic formulaic too much
going on but nothing actually happening
action superhero would be I've ever seen
we were halfway through the movie and
stuff still really hadn't happened
I've had one scare and a plane with a
character we didn't care about three
quarters before like they even the
villain and hero even met like at all
also ultra like powerful all-powerful
like world ending in the comics
yes villain is and then here he has his
one training moment and is able to
completely destroy him
yeah by himself oh well I mean world
ending and miss as well and took fun I
truly do not like Ryan Reynolds's
I don't think that I don't I don't like
anyone in this and such good people for
this film I really like a lot of the
actors that are in this and I didn't
enjoy any one they drove like insane I
need comfort I no longer knows how to
exist as like Adam II more I'm sure I'm
gonna get a lot of like messages about
this but Hal Jordan is boring and this
is what happens when you have a boring
character as the main character the only
interesting thing about Hal Jordan is
the thing they retconned in the comics
and then in and then base this entire
movie on which was that he went crazy
because of grief and loss and thought he
could change and fix the world and it
drove him mad that was the only
interesting thing
ever about Hal Jordan and know just know
I know I'm done I'm and I'm so mad I was
such a DC fan boy growing up and I still
kind of a.m. but they dig ruin some the
flames on the side of my face don't know
what to do anymore
I don't know you told me about him in
the comics being like you know I'm a cop
yeah face cop and and so here he starts
off he's obviously hurt by his father
he's making Deadpool light light light
light light jokes he's hurt by his
father to him because when his father's
bones
oh it's foot it hit me in the face oh
god he's traumatized by his father that
they it's what a trope that is also but
they visited in such a funny way yeah
it's one flashback while he's on a
flying mission cuz he's a pilot and one
flashback of him like seeing his dad go
off and be a pilot
and he's like dad are you scared and
he's like my job not to be sad and then
his dad like crashes and he's like
running up to the plane because that's
somehow oh wow
you can't run up to planes that's not
how that works but I'd love to play
things like that Adam before you get
there the plane explodes and it's so
traumatic it's such a stupid stupid
flashback and of course he's just
plagued by this this torment of his life
and and so he's like this guy who
doesn't play by the rules and he's like
most likely gonna kill himself in a
plane accident and then for some reason
the ring we've all seen the bachelor
sometimes the person is shouldn't get
the ring gets the ring I will say I'm
gonna this is gonna be a point of ire
for a lot of people but my one point
defense of the movie my only point of
defense of the movie or at least defense
of the criticism of the movie okay is I
get I think it was not done well and I
get where they were coming from with
computer generating the costume the
uniform oh right because it's generated
by the ring it's it's it's it's a light
construct just like everything else is
so a little bit of lack of reality of
the costume makes a little bit of sense
more so than anything else I more says
anything else in this movie but the idea
that the costume the uniform isn't
exactly real yeah
actually makes some sense yeah okay you
want to know what my least favorite line
was of course I do thank you it was I
used to sleep in and then I turned 11
I remember that I blacked it out I
blacked out so I heard what happened I
blacked out every moment of the movie as
it progressed so I so I'm surprised I
can talk about it this much because I
don't remember any of it what a jerk
thing to say yeah like those people it's
like this I was just having this
conversation it's like when you're like
man I'm gonna indulge tomorrow and I'm
gonna sleep in and those people that
wake up at 6:00 every morning and love
to shove it in your face or like I'm
sleeping in - and it's like you you're
such a jerk stop making me feel bad you
know that that's not sleeping in it is a
Marvel Marvel that DC gets amazing women
to play Amanda no I'm speaking of a man
that you want to know what's a real
Marvel oh wow this guy's been infected
by an alien let's just all hang out with
them for a while with no no necessary
like let's put him in quarantine wear
somebody wear a glove for God's
normal size he just got way more
he just claims that he's like all of
your memories put on a glove wear a
condom I don't care just do something
more than just act normally can never be
too safe
first one is my friend Bree who I love
dearly and I've never deal orison yeah
I've never disagreed with her ever Oh
God
I'll breathe because your heart is so
pure not that we are great it will make
you feel sorry for Ryan as he tries his
best in a crappy movie I don't think he
tried his best I don't think he did I
really don't I mean ah that's so mean to
say and what does shitty thing to say
know about another actor cuz like I
Betty I mean of course he's trying and
like it's a big action movie like
superhero movie they've been doing great
for ever I'm sure he was very excited
but like I don't know I didn't see any
spark anything good from Ryan at all I
like Ryan Reynolds I'm sure he's a very
nice guy
he he's just he's coasting I'm Ryan
Reynolds this movie he's not trying to
really do anything else I'm sorry
like I will I will say I don't think he
tried and I'm not saying you gotta sing
lightly save the movie but just watching
it there's no there's no like I'm gonna
try to make the best out of a bad
situation happen well it deserves every
joke Deadpool slash Ryan Reynolds makes
about it yes with some more work it
could have been a decent movie you know
I really think it could have so maybe
that's where my dear this is coming from
I see it like the bones of something
that could have been fun at least it's
just a lazy attempt from beginning to
end and I'm mad and they he Green
Lantern as a concept deserves more
people humanity
that was so beautiful my god that was
before you gonna be okay no this is why
I avoided this movie I am forever ruined
you owe me so much
the Abbas baby bee emoji movie and this
III get the I get Rumpelstiltskin credit
on your firstborn child thank you so
much for watching everyone I will see
you all next week
follow Cody on all of his social medias
and we'll see you soon bye the brightest
day in blackest night
[Music]
[Applause]
you